un bus repleto de razones para migrar
estos nicaragüenses dejan su país
buscando alcanzar Estados Unidos en el
camino sin embargo se encuentran con un
gran primer obstáculo la corrupción de
las autoridades hondureñas Todo es
dinero Todo es dinero te ponen pero te
dicen que por una letra o por un número
o un documento no está bien y que no
pasas tal como Jessica Centeno muchos
nicaragüenses denuncian que los puestos
de migración en Honduras pueden llegar a
cobrarles desde 40 a 250 dólares debido
a supuestas irregularidades en sus
papeles un monto que deben pagar si
pretenden seguir con su periplo hasta
Estados Unidos es un viaje que no se
tiene descanso como madre porque toca
luchar más de lo normal que una madre
lucha por sus hijos
y si se corre mucho riesgo la pobreza y
la represión por parte del gobierno
Daniel Ortega son algunos de los motivos
compartidos por los cuales los
nicaragüenses siguen optando por migrar
por la actriz que hay en Nicaragua
estamos sin trabajo y las cosas están la
canasta básica pues no tenemos Con qué
comprarla no hay facilidad ahora con
todo caro y sin trabajo entonces por eso
es el viaje Después que hacemos para ver
si buscamos una mejor vida más de
100.000 nicaragüenses migraron de forma
irregular a Estados Unidos entre enero y
agosto de este año según la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza de dicho
país en múltiples ocasiones Ortega ha
asegurado que El Éxodo responde a las
sanciones estadounidenses que han
afectado la situación de la nación
centroamerica